when it comes to presents guys can
sometimes have trouble picking the right
thing you know that guys and ladies you
know what I'm talking about but don't
you worry our own Andy Richter has some
surefire gift suggestions for guys who
are stuck this holiday season Andy
thanks Conan ok guys I'm here to help
you know for the lovely lady in your
life
how about stuffing her stocking with
this
it's a beautiful Cartier bow on blue
watch for $11,500 she's gonna love it
and she'll love you for it yeah I gotta
say any that's pretty steep that's an
expensive watch and if you've got a
four-year-old in the house they'll love
this gorgeous hand-carved English
rocking zebra for $9,000 it's a great
way for junior to rock in the new year
Andy very very few people can afford
that or if your kids are a little older
they'll enjoy this $12,000 air mace
bicycle long after the tinsel comes down
okay Andy stop there these are all
incredibly expensive gifts a lot of guys
don't have that kind of money just lying
around well they would if they got their
testicle injured in the state of
Illinois
they got their testicles injured in the
state of Illinois Andy what the hell are
you talking about roll the tape Alan
when it comes to workplace injuries
every state sets different compensation
rates and the state with the highest
maximum compensation rate for testicle
damage is Gillan Oy that's right if you
hurt your balls in Illinois you could
get more than 73,000 dollars that's a
lot of Jack for your sack but don't hurt
your balls in Minnesota their maximum
compensation is a whole lot less and
getting your testicle entered in
Illinois is easy just move to Illinois
get a job in light manufacturing or
construction damage one of your balls
$73,000 buys a lot of nice gift Merry
Christmas guys
[Applause]
[Music]
I sure didn't see that ending
[Laughter]